I'm going to start uh first with some of
the questions you people asked uh
hopefully I will cover them throughout
you my presentation okay hopefully I'll
answer them as we go along and so let me
just State what the questions are and it
turns out that the questions that you
folks ask are I would say almost 90%
what people ask out there as well so
it's like you hit them right on the nose
and you can see as soon as I put the
questions here you'll see why uh the
first one was and they're not in any
certain order but I'll put them in an
order in which I'm going to be
addressing them okay so the first one is
Richard feeman he was a Nobel Prize
winner in physics okay once remarked
that he could not explain exactly why
two magnets attract and repel right we
have two magnets we don't know why they
what caused is the mechanism right
that's what we're asking right uh could
you tell us that's your question could
you tell us why the current standard
explanation does not work and how the
Rope hypothesis comes in I'm G to be
answering that question what testable
predictions second question does rope
Theory make and to ex to the extent that
these predictions have been tested in
practice have they been borne out so we
will address that issue as well number
three uh where does where does not there
does not seem to be a way to explain how
the ropes don't get tangled excellent
question that people ask say hold it you
got these gazillions of qu of ropes out
there in the world right electromagnetic
ropes as we call them that were
replacing the electromagnetic wave with
right and people say well holdie you got
these ropes you're talking about a
physical entity exactly and they say how
don't they how don't they how is it that
they don't get tangled perfect question
99% %
150% of the people ask that question
please define touch for us and show us
how you would solve this problem and the
last one is also do the roast pass
through each other okay those are
standard questions everybody asks him
and hopefully I will address all those
questions today okay in the uh
presentation so I want to give you a
little presentation of what the problem
is where where we have a problem today
especially in so-called science in
so-called mathematical physics which
Styles itself as physics and I'm going
to say that mathematical physics I'm
going to argue here mathematical physics
has nothing at all to do with physics
okay so I want to put that right up
front Okay now uh let's start with some
of the problems and one of the big
problems we have today is gravity we
have no idea what causes gravity here I
have a little pencil I hope you can all
see this okay here okay we have a pencil
we let let go of it and it falls
downwards yeah you don't believe me do
it yourself okay I I think everybody has
had something drop from their hands and
it falls to the floor okay all we need
is one experiment in the last 10,000
years and we know something about
gravity everything falls to the floor
right what's the problem the first
problem is that not a single
mathematical physicist so-called
physicist not a single indiv idual
coming out of uh Cambridge or uh Harvard
can explain to
you how that happens what causes it to
happen Okay general relativity has
irrational explanation what's the
irrational explanation why is it
irrational well because they say
SpaceTime is warm let's forget for a
second space because people think well
space is maybe an object a
threedimensional blah blah blah forget
about space Bas what they're telling you
is time is warp that's the
explanation and when you say time is
warp what does that even mean what sense
does that make okay that's why it's an
irrational one because they're taking a
concept called time and they're saying
it's warped and because it's warped
that's what prevents the Earth from
flying out of the solar system which is
gravity you know uh the Earth stuck to
the Sun or the moon to the earth why
doesn't the moon fly out of the solar
system system because time is war they
have this depression a canvas that they
illustrate and they say the moon rolls
around the earth it's like it's there's
a wall there and the moon can fly out
and what what you're staring at is warp
time that's why it's IR
irrational quantum mechanics what
explanation do they have for Gravity
well again they work in the world of the
small right and if you take that pencil
and you let go of it it right it falls
to the floor and they say well we should
be able to answer that because we're
talking about at least the world of here
within earth and what's the explanation
first of all they don't have really an
explanation of gravity but the one they
give you out there that you will find is
negative momentum transfer that means
that you you send rocks out right you
send all these rocks out and instead of
delivering push they deliver pull
okay that's what negative momentum
transfer means it means you're sending
some kind of particle out with negative
momentum when it hits you instead of
pushing you away it drags you inwards
that's only a
mathematical uh I mean you put a
negative sign in the equation you can
get away with that but get away with
that in the lab try
throwed or the tabl if you attracted so
we got a problem there because all these
are irrational
explanations so you cannot explain you
cannot give a physical interpretation to
gravity using equations math numbers or
whatever that's the issue okay and so
the question is how did we arrive here
and and the the the answer is that the
scientific method is screwed up in in
short I mean that's that's a problem for
the last 400 years since the days of the
17th century so-called Scientific
Revolution it's the mathematicians who
took over physics and Science and they
imposed on everybody on the world you in
the world they imposed on them their
notion of what science is and what
physics is and what physics and science
is according to mathematical physics is
experiment measurement and an equation
okay so you do an experiment you measure
and then you come up with an equation to
describe what you just saw and you
publish that's it and so you ask them
what about the explanation what is the
cause what is the explanation oh that's
not part of science that's not part of
physics that's
philosophy and you say Oh I thought that
was physics and so that's where we have
our first problem we have a a clash
against what we have today that math
that science and physics is all about uh
experiments measurement and
equations and so if you ask why don't we
have rational explanations because those
are not part of science those are
considered part of philosophy philosophy
of physics philosophy of science or
whatever but they're not part of what
they call science or physics and so
these people give you a physical
interpretation an irrational one and
when you receive that you say well that
doesn't sound very irrational yeah we
don't care because that's philosophy
that's the answer that's what we have
today okay today here we're going to
talk about something else we're gon to
talk about real physics we're going to
try to give you an explanation of how
this happens okay how gravity actually
works which is totally different than
what these people have suggested for the
last 400 years and the other issue here
is that you know the types of um what we
have for science what these people say
is science which is measurement uh
equations Etc you know uh predictions
observation none of that helps answer
the question that we're asking we're
asking I want to know what causes this
to fall to the floor that's how simple
it is and they're saying well we do
observation we do measurement we can
tell you how fast it falls we here's the
equation but you're not telling me why
and that's when they dismiss and say
well that's part of philosophy so the
questions we're asking are not being
answered because science is not Des or
The Way It Is defined today is not
designed to answer those types of
questions that's the that's the root of
the problem okay so let's I want to just
clarify that up front
Okay okay so so what's the
issue um we're say let me give you a
scenario here okay and uh I hope you can
picture this in your mind you're here
with your
friend okay and you look out at the
distance and you see a fellow maybe a
farmer right pulling on a
rope and at the other end of the Rope
there's a donkey or a horse very simple
scenario so this guy's going like this
pulling on a rope and the horse or the
donkey comes towards him and so your
fellow your friend asked you how did the
donkey move towards the farmer how how
how did that happen it's very simple
five-year-old can answer that question
the guy pulled on the rope and the
donkey came closer to him because he's
tied to the Rope it's all physically
connected no problem there we all
understand
that same scenario same exact scenario
but you can't see the
Rope okay so you see a farmer going like
that maybe because there's too much
light in the background so the Rope
Blends in with a background for whatever
reason maybe your eyesight is not good I
don't know the question is you see the
guy going like that and the donkey comes
towards the farmer now your friend asks
you how did the far how did the donkey
come closer to the farmer and you oh
we'll never figure it out uh we need to
run more tests I need to run an
experiment uh we'll never you know maybe
sometime in the future we'll figure it
out and the only difference in between
scenario a and scenario B is that here
you can see the Rope the mediator and
here you
cannot that was the only difference okay
so so we're we're getting to the to the
problem the problem is that people say
well if I can't see it or touch it it's
not there and there we have the
difference between objective and
subjective which no one has defined by
the way in the last 10,000 years
objective is what comes out of the scene
out of the phenomenon that's what comes
out what that's what's in there for real
whether you can see it or not subjective
is what you can see hear taste smell
that's all subjective and so if you
can't see it or or touch it people say
well it's not there well not true it
could be there that's objective whether
it's there or not you know whether you
can see or touch it that's subjective
okay and so we need to distinguish what
uh what is objective from subjective and
here I'm defining I'm saying objective
is what comes out of the scene whether
you can see it or not or touch it or
whatever okay okay so that's the issue
and uh so we have we have this uh this
issue where the mathematicians have used
the term action at a distance so when
they see the D the uh farmer moving his
hands like that and the donkey M moving
towards him but they can't see the robe
they say oh it's action at a distance
well action at a distance is an
explanation uh so-called scientific
version of black magic of Witchcraft
they're saying it just happens you
haven't explained anything did God do it
I mean how did that happen and what
they're saying is you know it's action
at a distance you know meaning we don't
know well we didn't see it happen we
didn't we can't experiment on it what
are you g to experiment here you know
you can't see anything be above it you
can't see anything below it something is
in contact with this
pencil and otherwise it wouldn't fall to
the floor and you say well is that true
are you saying that something really
came in contact but I can't see it or
touch
it and so the issue here is that you
know you go to what is an object what is
a thing you know because if you say that
nothing came in contact with a pencil
you're doing black magic you're doing
action at a distance you're doing you
know
witchcraft but uh we have to assume that
if we're going to do explain this
rationally that there is something in
contact with a pencil either something
pushing or something pulling From Below
that's why this falls to the ground
otherwise we're doing black magic we're
saying action at a distance which is the
scientific version of Witchcraft okay
and this takes up to the issue of what
is an object what is a thing no one has
defined the term in the last 10,000
years what is a thing and people say
well it's that what you can see or touch
that's the general notion that people
have well we can't see the air the air
is made out of atoms no different than
your chair you can see the chair and say
okay that's a thing but the air it's not
a thing because I can't see it it's made
out of atoms it's just loose atoms but
air is a thing I breathe it you know I
take it in I I see I move my hand and I
touch something there and how about
touch well touch I can't touch the chair
on the other side of the of the planet
do I have to go and touch the chair for
the chair to become an object or was it
an object before I touched
it and so the the problem is the
definition the notion we have of what an
object is what a thing is a thing is not
that which you can see or touch which is
our normal notion of objects and thing
is that which has shape all objects in
the universe have shape if you have if
you can think of one that's not uh an
object that does not have shape please
let me know okay any exception to the
room it's a Universal criteria criteria
in other words every every object has
shape and that's the definition of the
word object that doesn't mean that you
can see or touch it especially anything
that is subatomic below the itom okay we
can't even see let alone touch anything
below that so the issue here is that we
had a wrong definition or a notion wrong
notion of what an object is and here
we're saying that here's an object
some something here right or above that
is in contact with a pencil that we
cannot see or touch but it's a thing
because it has shape it's a shape that
we cannot see or touch once we make that
assumption it changes the whole picture
now we're in a different ballgame now
we're no longer in this magical realm of
mathematical physics or whatever so we
had to distinguish what an object is
that's bottom line and the only word you
will not find defined in any uh book
textbook your physics today and I
challenge you to do this go out there
and look for any textbook of physics see
if you can find the word object defined
you would think that the first word they
would Define in the in the in the
textbook is the word object because you
can't do physics without an object if
you remove all objects in the universe
all atoms everything so that you have
absolutely nothing what's happening what
are you seeing what's what's taking
place what phenomenon is occurring no
you have to have objects and no one ever
defined the word object and everybody
has this this loose notion that it's uh
that which we can see or touch and that
was the wrong definition or the wrong
notion now an object is that which has
shape not all objects can be seen or
touch we do not run an experiment to
prove the existence of a chair and say
oh now it is an object because I can
finally touch it no it was an object
before you touched and besides touching
or seeing requires two objects the one
doing the seeing or the touching so it's
a an irrational definition or irrational
notion to apply to the word object in a
scientific context once we have that
settled and now we're in a different
ball game like I'm saying now we're
going to be talking about real objects
and the objects we propose for U for
gravity is the a ropik uh entity now
what do we mean by people say well it's
a rope it's made out of atoms no no no
no we're talking about the subatomic
world so this is not made out of atom
we're saying that whatever entity is
there very thin extremely thin
unimaginably thin thing looks like a DNA
like rope it looks like this two twine
threads that's what it is and light
consists of a torsion of this rope
torsion it's the fastest thing known to
man nothing is faster than torsion
because it doesn't go anywhere you put
the uh you put the Rope your
grandmother's rope where she hangs her
clothes right across two poles and you
put two clothes spins at each end you
move one the other one moves
instantaneously why because nothing went
anywhere they just twirled in place and
the only thing that essentially moved
was a signal along the Rope it
propagated along the rope and so that's
when you can find out that a torsion
wave is much faster than a transverse
wave or or a longitudinal wave
longitudinal wave for example uh sound
and transfers waves is what they always
thought was light but see those are all
one way the the torsion wave travels in
both directions simultaneously okay goes
from your eye to mine and mine to yours
at the same time we're both receiving a
signal
constantly so not only are we saying
that uh light is a torion of a DNA like
entity that's between any two atoms but
now we can explain gravity because we
have a physical connection from atom to
atom and if you look at number one there
um the Muller pull you see that there um
Ed yeah maybe you can put that up
there okay and uh let's see if we can
read this let me let me see if I can
read because it's kind of small
unfortunately you know but here let me
read it for for anyone who who needs uh
to know what they're saying this is what
Richard Muller says he's from the UC
Berkeley okay so he says for example if
you have the Earth there's a big Mass
here and you have you with your little
Mass here every atom on the earth is
pulling on every atom of you you're also
pulling on it the amazing thing about
gravity is that it goes right through
things so what is he saying he's saying
look every atom on Earth is pulling on
every atom of you and you're pulling on
it uh I mean I think it's
straightforward what you saying I'm not
sure if anyone missed anything
here Gravity is a force of pull of some
kind you have to have a mediator between
the pencil and the Earth and what we're
saying is that every atom that makes up
this pencil is tied to every atom on
Earth okay and uh people say I can't see
it I can't taste it I can't smell it
yeah I know you will not be able to see
smell taste it because it's an invisible
intangible entity and therefore now we
answer one of the first questions there
there's no test no experiment you can
run for something that is invisible and
intangible because when you go to the
lab what you're gonna be uh testing
essentially experimenting on is
invisibility and intangibility you're
GNA use your hand and your eyes and
we're saying that you can't use your
hand or your eyes for an
intangible invisible entity like we're
suggesting that connects any two atoms
but here you're you have Miller saying
every atom on Earth is pulling on every
atom of you you're pulling on every atom
of it how do you how do you explain how
do you how do you illustrate that unless
you put some kind of connection between
every atom in the universe every atom of
you to every atom on Earth okay so
that's what we're saying that's what's
happening and now we can see the
mechanism if you go to number three
there I think it's number yeah number
three it'll show you why a a spoon falls
to the floor that uh every Atom from the
spoon is connected to every atom on
Earth as it falls the the ropes in in
this case right every atom is connected
to other atom on Earth with ropes right
electromagnetic ropes very thin very
invisible very Untouchable ropes right
and what's happening as it falls the
ropes fan out so if you take them to
Infinity all the ropes come together and
it's like a single rope like a single
coaxial but as they come closer to the
object in this case the Earth they all
fan out and each one acts
individually and so that's why you have
the acceleration of gravity because you
have more and more ropes working or
acting
individually that's the mechanism that
we're proposing okay okay and so we have
a physical mechanism of why uh explains
the acceleration of gravity okay that's
that's the point here and uh so yeah we
have this and uh then people ask well uh
hold they have all these ropes in the in
the universe and again people say how
come they don't get
tangled again looking at C touch people
have this in the back of their mind they
can't get away from that and no problem
the first issue is that in Quantum
mechanic at least they don't treat the
subject in general relativity but in
quantum mechanics what you have is the
same thing you have what is known as
superposition and what they have
superposition of States because they're
going to talk about math they're not
going to talk about physics they're not
going to put objects in there they're
gonna say well we have the wave and and
it has so much vibration of the field
they're gonna be talk about numbers but
what they're saying essentially in in a
roundabout way is two particles can
occupy the same place at the same time
and there I think if you look at number
07 there where I pulled out some quotes
from so-called physicist or people who
are into physics those Quotes come out
of qu uh quora then next that one there
I don't know if you can read all that
let's see if I can read them for you
give me a second here uh let me get it
up there okay first one says the answer
is yes two electrons can occupy the same
position they have to be in different
states though because of the poly
Exclusion Principle that's out a PhD
student inal physics another one a
Quantum physicist says in a
multi-particle equation it treats
several particles as being in the same
place and then you have Quantum that's a
Quantum physicist and then another PhD
in electrical engineering says it's more
correct to say that the particle has no
position so they give you the runaround
but they're saying the same thing
they're saying that according to Quantum
Mechanics super position says that two
particles can occupy the same place the
same space the same position and even
worse they say that one particle can be
at two places at the same time it's like
nobody questions that but when it comes
to the Rope people say how come they
they they don't tangle it's the same
question they're saying that a single
piece of the Rope you know occupies the
same position Place space as another
rope and how can that possibly be well
why didn't you ask the question with
mechanics I mean there everybody accepts
to say yeah that's obvious right it's
okay no no first ask the question in
quantum mechanics before you ask me the
question so that's the first answer okay
but we have a better answer than that
and again it's that definition that the
word object has nothing to do with see
or touch in the subatomic World we're
saying the same thing as quantum
mechanics objects can be at the same
place at the same time we don't say the
opposite of what quantum mechanics says
that one object can be at two places at
once which is to us is irrational but we
do agree with Quantum that two objects
can be at the same place at the same
time so now we get into the question of
touch you know before I can cut across a
rope can cross uh another across another
one they has to touch then you can cross
across cut across or or a tangle right
because something stops it but before
before you can get to that point you
have to touch it two things have to
touch the scissor has to touch the paper
before you cut it okay so the question
is what does the word touch mean and
again no one in the last 10,000 years
defined the word touch so important uh
for the purposes of physics and so what
are we saying we're saying look touch is
when two objects become one when there's
no space between two objects as long as
there space between two objects you
haven't touch it like you know I have
two fingers here right I press as hard
as I can or against the table and it
turns out that you know there's always
space in between the two fingers so the
fingers have not touched in the 3D macro
world of ours there is no such thing as
touch because there's always space in
between any two atoms they don't blend
to be for to form one atom or when they
do then you can say that we have touch
but in normal uh every day things we
have no such thing as touch but people
say oh you touched your finger no I
didn't because there's space in between
the only way you can Define touch in
irrational that you can use it in IR
rational manner is if there's no space
between two objects meaning that two
objects have become one there's no space
empty space you know between
them okay and so the question is you
know in the microscopic world in the
subatomic world uh the Rope has the ab
uh to go through because it doesn't have
the property of touch okay that's an
assumption and it's the same assumption
Quantum makes with particles so please
don't hold it against the theory okay I
mean if you're gonna hit the theory with
touch get first quantum mechanics okay
don't come to me and tell me oh quantum
mechanics can't explain it no they
cannot okay okay so uh all I can say is
first uh the reason this pencil falls to
the floor is because every atom of this
pencil is a tied to every atom on Earth
you cannot explain it what is this push
gravity which is particles pushing the
pencil because the pencil on the other
side of the planet is falling also
towards the center of the planet you
know the one in China and what the
particles over there are pushing it in
against mine you know why you would have
to explain that you would say why does
why do the particles here push it that
direction the particles on the other
side of the universe push it or the
Earth push it the opposite direction and
you cannot explain that the only way you
can explain this is if every atom of the
pencil like Mr Richard mull said is tied
to every atom on Earth as it falls the
um Clos the distance between the Earth
and the pencil becomes shorter and
shorter shorter the ropes fan out and
you have the acceleration of gravity now
we have AAL explanation at least for
this whether you believe it or not is a
separate issue we have an explanation
that's all I'm saying and as far as the
Rope uh for light we have an explanation
of what light is we're saying it's a
torsion along the Rope meaning that
every atom is connected you know like if
my fists here are considered the atoms
and you have the rope in between tight
being pulled tight and you have a
torsion moving from atom to atom now we
can explain light why it's so
fast that we can say look we have the
grand un Theory because in one mechanism
we can explain both gravity and Light
which is what they've been looking at
for so many hundreds of years now all
right I got a quick question bill so
like up for a question all right so
suppose I get out of this planet and I
just I'm just floating out into space
let's just say my my body does so like
forever incessantly will will the Rope
never break the like the Rope will just
be infinitely elastic
okay uh Ed let me just uh a little piece
here that maybe I should clarify which
is important to clarify give me a second
here we're saying that all there is in
the universe you know according to
quantum mechanics and according to
general relativity strength Theory
essentially all of these uh mathematical
physics there uh assumption their bottom
line assumption is that everything is
just particles discrete particles and so
they have this particle moving in that
direction the other one the other
direction all they talk about is
particles particles be being created
from the vacuum uh particles that came
into being from The Big Bang out of
nothing they cannot explain that either
they say that's an unscientific question
we're saying that this is all there is
in the universe there's a single closed
loop thread like a rubber band here that
you can see right this thread turns into
every atom connected to every other atom
through an electromagnetic rope made out
of the same single thread twine P twine
thread and it goes into making the atom
which the atom itself is made out of
those threads continuing to another rope
to continuing to another atom another
rope another atom and so on down the
line so if we we if we were to
untangle every atom in the universe and
every rope in the universe we would end
up with a single closed loop thread
we're saying this is this is the
Assumption we're saying this is all that
really exists ultimately in the universe
this floating in space this has turned
into every atom connected to every robe
connected to every atom to connected to
every Rob so now you ask does the thread
essentially disintegrate it doesn't that
single thread is Untouchable it can't
touch itself it it kind of winds around
itself forms the atoms and you have the
property known as
touch or you know essentially called
colliding you know the fact that you
have some kind of wall there is with the
atom and above anything below the atom
has no property to
touch and you can't break it either this
is something terrible at terrible that
you can tear right that's all right and
then your explanation as to how come
ropes don't Tangles that they actually
can pass each other and occupy like the
same like you know the same uh location
and they're able to do that
because and one of the issues here that
people have a a lot of trouble with that
because they're saying how can that
possibly
be has been telling them for the last
hundred years the same exact thing two
particles can be at the same place at
the same time as long as they have what
is known as a different state a
different vibration state so to speak so
they're saying the same thing as as as I
am I mean we have no difference in that
sense we're saying the subatomic world
Works a little different and saying is
you can't use the word touch in the
submic world that's bottom line okay so
okay and so in the micro level world
since the ropes belong in that category
their properties are just intrinsically
different so that you know the ropes can
pass through each other and that's why
ropes out here can't pass through each
other not only that let me let me add to
that a little more the the thread the
single thread as we call it has
properties that we see today in gases
liquids and
solids this magical thread uh Wonder
Woman's rope lasso right it has
properties that include solids liquids
and gases in other words it it it
inherently has these properties that's
why the thread is able to mimic all
these properties in our macro world of
atoms okay okay but uh yeah so in answer
to your question yes and in addition to
we have this the fact that the robe has
this versatility you know that uh in the
subatomic World it has these strange
properties that we can only make an
assumption of you know you have to make
an assumption at some point and say well
what if right so you make a supposition
and you say let us assume that Mother
Nature has this single thread out there
this is what it is and this turns into
all these atoms ropes Etc but they don't
have the ability to touch unless they
are atom or above once you get into the
atomic world then yes now you have the
ability to touch what we call Touch
actually Collision because you're really
not blending them you're not eliminating
space between the the atoms because
otherwise they wouldn't be single atoms
right but other than that uh you know
you don't have touch below the atomic
level and you start having this
so-called touch property after the atom
after the atom is formed now now you can
Collide things other than that that's
what I'm having a hard time
understanding because it's like so the
the the small ropes in the micro
Universe can but the ropes excuse me got
a cough and the macro Universe can and
you know and everything's made out of
the electromagnetic ropes in the micro
macro world so so how come the ones in
the macro world can
touch yeah BEC why because now you have
a volume you you've made a ball which is
the atom you know the atom is not this
uh B's atom Neil bore Neil Neil's Bor
atom which is a proton uh which is
orbited by an electron bead that's not
our atom our atom uh in fact I think I
have it there I know I didn't send you
the atom but you can see um
how can I show you this essentially the
Rope turns into the thre each one of the
threads of the Rope turns into the
electron shell it's a so the atom is
really a ball which is the shell which
encapsulates you can imagine it as a um
um as a star all these uh single threads
coming out of that gazillions of them
and they're encapsulated by and what we
call the electron shell and what these
people have always looked at when they
say look I saw an electron bead you know
right here what they're looking at is a
location on the electron shell or
electron membrane electron balloon it's
a balloon that is encapsulating a star
so it's a different model alog together
I do have in the videos that I have uh
in my channel you'll see that there so
you just got to look at that over there
but my point here is that we have a
different atom it's not this electron
bead that orbits or is somewhere around
the proton d uh proton ball bowling ball
right it's a totally different model and
again one of the things that Quantum has
never been able to explain and which was
the reason of why Quantum came into
being in the first place is they could
not explain why the electron which is a
negative particle and why doesn't it
fall to the positive proton if positive
attracts negative and to this day they
cannot explain the mechanism of why the
electron stops at a certain point and
then just keeps being around the proton
ball why doesn't it fall directly into
the ball or why does it spontaneously
fly away they cannot explain either one
they've never explained that and that
was the reason they went into quantum
mechanics so to this day we have no
explanation for that so okay so when
there's so many ropes just together in a
mass there's so many of them cuz that's
what you mean by volume that's what
makes it able to be able to be
touched no no no the Rope is not able to
be touch it's the atom that is for the
first
time smallest entity that has a property
of touch or Collis okay so let's just go
to the micro universe so atams and the
micro Universe can touch just the ropes
between them can correct oh okay I get
it now all right but but
you created a ball you created a ball
with the threads remember we're talking
about threads we should not confuse rope
with threads threads with ropes there's
always a different thread is you know
what makes up the rope and what makes up
the atom and we're saying the thread can
go right through the thread because it
doesn't have the property of touch the
property of touch uh is an emergent
property that occurs when you have this
ball this volume called an atom hydrogen
atom being the smallest one right and
that's for the first time that you have
not the ability to touch really but the
ability to bang and coll have Collide
you know this is the this is the
proposal okay uh but isn't an atom just
made out of ropes or is it ropes and
something else
Reds okay we gotta keep those separate
people get them
confusing I just want to clarify that
threads okay atoms are made out of
threads but the ropes connect the atom
correct and the question is if you have
two atoms then you have this situation
where you have two balls right and let's
assume this is a I don't know a helium
atom which which is bigger than the uh
hydrogen atom right and they have the
ability to hit each other to collide
they can't occupy the same space they do
cannot really go through each other un
unless you go under certain
circumstances which is beyond the scope
of this uh talk here today but they they
Collide for the first time because now
you have a volume of of all these
threads that are making up these two uh
spheres okay so that's when the ability
to touch comes into play but when you
have this when you have just a thread
well I hope you can see
it then uh this one doesn't have the
ability to prevent another thread like
for example here right to go through
each other they just go it doesn't have
an ability to stop it okay that's the
assumption that we're making we make
these assumptions in order to understand
the theories founded upon that and yeah
uh what happens in the subatomic world
is a little different than what happens
in the macro world of atoms and above
and Quantum has already verified a lot
of that stuff so we're not too far away
from what Quantum is proposing okay and
so the reason the ropes don't touch is
just because of the intrinsic property
of the Rope of the thread of the thread
yeah for that matter the the Rope itself
okay yeah have the ability under certain
circumstances because now you asked the
question about uh Electro um magnetism
right here we have two magnets okay I
hope you can see them here yeah okay and
you know these are magnets from the
refrigerator okay and you have see those
two dark circles those are magnet right
and you can see how they attach each
other and so the first question that we
have is is there nothing
here and people say well I can't see
anything I can't touch anything so
there's nothing there no that's not the
definition of anything of something of
object of thing the definition of thing
is a shape if it there's something there
that has shape now it doesn't have the
ability to see and touch by humans okay
but obviously this magnet recognizes
something in there because it's acting
upon it okay so how does this magic work
and so and so uh if you look there uh
the one that you have there right now it
shows is that let's see if I can explain
with my hands well let me show you with
my hands let's explain first uh because
we all are acquainted with North and
South right of a magnet and just imagine
ropes two guys um skipping ropes right
there's two guys in parallel skipping
ropes now the ropes let's assume they go
against each other so they're facing
each other they're both skipping ropes
the ropes are banging against each other
it pushes them away okay because it goes
like this now we turn one of them 180
degrees like we do with a magnet now
we're going to say instead of North
North it's going to be north south so we
turn it around 180 degrees now they're
both going like this okay you got that
so far so now when one comes down the
other one comes up and now you have
attraction so here you had
repulsion and here you have ATT traction
one coming down the other one uh uh
getting to it you know touching it and
pulling and so now we have the mechanism
of what's between those two magnets
we're saying if the threads not row but
threads gazillions of threads swinging
in One Direction and the other one
swinging in the same direction they
attract and if they uh swing in the
opposite direction when you turn the
magnet around 180 degrees now they push
each other away so have attraction and
and
repulsion uh with one mechanism you
other essentially the The Swinging of
threats and so now we explanation
finally a physical interpretation now
whether you believe or not that's a
separate issue we're just giving you a
mechanism that you can you know sink
your teeth into gotcha alrighty well
yeah thanks for that presentation and
before we move on so you also get Bill
Gat book his magnum opus that was
published in 1999 he's done four
editions of it called why God doesn't
exist you should just uh you can get his
email on um his uh website and just uh
give them uh 40 bucks via PayPal and
he'll send you a copy like you didn't
mind it's a good book it's like about
500 pages long it has everything he
teaches about physics and his uh online
videos in here so yeah it's a i s highly
suggest reading
it all righty and then uh Keith did you
have any questions for Bill yeah I can
think of three things um I have like a
relatively simple question and then I
have like kind of a hard question so
let's go with the simple ones I don't
like hard
questions terms of like what can your
theory account for something that's all
um the simple one is how does it differ
from String Theory right
because let me answer that because a lot
of people have that they say oh string
Rogue you know it's all the same thing
no you keep in mind two things the first
one is string theory is a mathematical
it's not even a theory mathematics
doesn't have any Theory mathematics just
description descriptions are not
theories an explanation is a theory when
you explain something then you have a
theory and all the explanation from
mathematical physics where they go
whether you bring them from General
altivity quantum mechanics or strength
Theory are all mathematical descriptions
and not one of them is a rational Theory
it's not rational because they're using
Concepts as physical objects they say
the field energy Mass all those are
mathematical concept time you know those
are mathematical concept so that's the
first issue the second issue is that if
you look at strength Theory all they're
saying all they're saying is that what
is an what is a particle so they're
they're like trying to justify quantum
mechanics which is a particle theory and
they say what is a particle well
particle is really a a uh they call it a
string but it's not even a string that's
misleading as well what they're talking
about is onedimensional
line a mathematical concept a
onedimensional line has nothing to do
with physics it's got to do solely with
this notion that they had of geometry
that a point is a Zero Dimensional
nothing just location and what is a line
line is a one-dimensional whatever
because there's no such monster as a one
dimensional anything that we can even
imagine so what they take is they take
that one-dimensional line not string and
they tie it and they make a circle with
it and they say oh we have a particle
because now that that single
one-dimensional line is vibrating and
that's what a particle is so it's got
nothing at all to do with uh the Rope
model that we're presenting there's is a
mathematical Theory uh really not even a
theory it's not Theory it's just
mathematics
description and ours is a physical
explanation for how the universe works
so we have big difference there big uh
dividing line so that's the first answer
to your
question and our next one was it h give
me the hard one now all right all right
so you say that time is not what say
general or special relativity says it is
so one of the reasons that people sort
of don't question it is because it makes
certain predictions like like uh for
example that The Closer you are to a
large source of gravity like the Earth
or a black hole or the closer you get to
the speed of light time slows down and
so we put satellites in orbit and we
notice that their clocks are different
than the ones on Earth um that seems to
confirm what general relativity says
but okay very
good I think he's dealt with that you
fellows are asking the exact questions
and most people have you know in their
back of their mind so you're raising the
exact questions everybody asks and so
the first thing we have to say here is
in physics we have no use for time
whatsoever and people roll their eyes oh
Bill what are you saying here what do
you mean we have we've been dealing with
time since the days of Newton no in
physics we have no use for time let me
tell you why because physics is about
physical interpretations about
mechanisms about causes time has to do
with description I want to know how much
time it took the lion to catch the deer
I put the stopwatch and I say I took so
many SEC 30 seconds okay so far I only
have a description time can only be used
to describe I cannot explain anything
with time other than general relativity
where they say well warp time is gravity
you know that's the explanation they
give but time can only be a you know a
measurement of something okay and I can
measure how fast something runs how long
it took something to happen Okay that's
the first issue but then uh here we have
the problem with experiments okay we
have no use for experiments in science
either roll of eyes oh Bill what are you
saying here we have redefined science we
have redefined physics we're saying that
experiments have nothing to do with
physics you can do all the experiments
you want in your lab you know you can
get in in your dark basement do all the
experiments you want when you come to
the conference we want you to
explain and you say well let me do the
experiment for you no no don't do the
experiment I don't care about your
stupid experiment I want to see what
your explanation is for the experiment
in science we explain the experiments
not do them dude you can do a lot of
experiments not learn anything from them
you know or get the wrong conclusion so
you can do experiments like gravity Pro
B uh or uh GPS right you have GPS out
there and they say oh it works yeah it's
like um Thomas ala Edison said I have
not failed I just found 10,000 ways that
don't work what he was saying is he
tried one thing after another until it
worked until he got his filling for for
his light bulb and technology is like
that GPS was developed through trial and
error they sent gravity probe a first
then later on a few years later gravity
Pro B they measure and they say okay
here the the um uh satellites or the um
uh what is it the nuclear the atom
Atomic uh clocks ran at a certain speed
and here at another speed so they knew
that they knew that be for trial in err
they set one up and they say okay this
is the speed here and this is the speed
here this is how fast it goes here this
how fast it goes here so so they do all
these experiments and they can do GPS
the GPS proed that time is Warped that
there is such a thing as time that is
curved hopefully not just like you know
Quantum does not a computer does not
prove that um um you know that a
particle can be at two places at once in
Quantum okay just the fact that the
computer works doesn't mean that they
proved what their what their theory is
which is a particle can be at two places
at once and this is the same thing with
everything technology does not prove a
theory okay this is this a big error
this big misconception that people have
out there no the fact that GPS works and
the fact that they were able to measure
all these things it's just a description
we still don't have an explanation why
the moon doesn't fly out of the solar
system they don't have an explanation
for why this pencil falls to the floor
and you say hold it we have all these
satellites and we run all these
experiments all these things and they
cannot explain a single simple
experiment like a a spoon or a pen
falling to the floor so so the fact that
we use the word time and that they play
around with it so much aside from the
fact that they never defined it you can
look up the definition of time you'll go
nuts you won't find the definition time
is what a clock measures what is that I
mean they don't have a definition for
the word time but they use the word time
to explain and they say oh we we know
everything about time because look we
have GPS and all this other stuff out
there no we we have to be what is your
explanation what is the cause of gravity
what is the why does one clock run
slower than the other or faster than the
other you know and I always give the
experiment here let me show you this is
known as a clock okay um known as a sand
clock or an hourglass right and you turn
it around and all the uh grains start
falling to the other side right this is
a gravitational
clock if you're going to check time
Against Gravity this is the clock okay
and let me give you an
uh an experiment that you can do and
prove Einstein wrong Einstein said if
you take the clock farther out into
space right it'll uh run uh what is it
it'll run um slower and I'm sorry it'll
run faster and the one close to the
Earth runs uh slower right and that's
not true I take this clock my clock
right not an atomic clock and an
irrational and uh
um inadequate clock like an atomic clock
I'll take this one and this one runs
faster closer to the Center of the Earth
than if you take it out into outer space
and that destroys Einstein's uh
assumption for you know gravity which is
that clocks should run at a certain
speed out there and uh um you know at a
slower rate uh at the Earth so they're
saying that you know you're if you're if
you're at the top of uh I don't know the
Eiffel Tower uh your clock is going to
run at a different speed than the one at
the bottom of the uh Tower but yeah the
one at the bottom of the tower if you do
an atomic clock will run at a different
rate than if you use one of these guys
and so the which clock should we use I
mean this is an this is a gravitational
clock and if you don't believe that one
you know you have this other one like
the time dilation thing that they talk
about that you have two twins one leaves
to go to the uh black hole and come back
and after many years he's uh only
experienced according to his clock that
traveled with him he's only experienced
five years and the guys on Earth uh
experienced 50 years for example right
well this is very simple very very
simple how many times did the earth go
around the Sun that's the definition of
a year and so the the Earth went around
the Sun 50 times or five times it could
have been both and when this guy comes
back hopefully the Earth went around 50
times as the guy on Earth said and not
as his clock said Counting seconds while
traveling so it's it's all nonsense
mathematical nonsense which they
introduce into physics as a done deal
this is where the problem comes in so
the the issue with time we have to be
very careful first the word time has
never been defined and it will never be
defined by mathematical physicist
because it's not you know they're not
into definition that's primarily the
reason but then they don't care about
the definition of time because what
they're going to be using is seconds and
they're going to count how many years
you are you know how many candles you
got on your cake by putting seconds in
there so they put one candle for every
second that you live they say this is
how many seconds you've got I don't care
about seconds I want to know how many
times the Earth went around the Sun
that's
physics you know you can't have it both
ways you can't say well my clock
measures such and such things how so
many years I don't how many here's your
clock measured in seconds and while you
were moving I know how many times the
Earth went around the Sun and that's
going to be the definition of the word
year that's how many years I have so
it's very simple and then again they
don't have definition for the word time
that's the first one then they use time
if they want to use it in their
equations seconds minutes no problem but
don't bring them into the world of
physics don't tell me you can explain
something by saying that uh I'm going to
bend time time or or that gravity bends
time or some nonsense like that that's
not physics that's irrationality
completely anything else Keith you done
he seems
less less uh um not the opposite of
enamored less conflicted about quantum
mechanics then relativity so uh I wonder
if his rope theory has an explanation
for or if it's different than what's
called quantum entanglement you know
like so you take two particles and move
them apart and you change one property
and the opposite property appears even
if it's way like a million light years
away instantaneously with no speed of
light
[Music]
distance yeah they call it action at a
distance which we said a minute ago what
was it witchcraft black magic I mean if
if I have two particles here right here
here we have two
particles right and they're separated we
can say it's a million years it doesn't
matter they could be just that far away
no problem what we're say what these
people are saying is this one moves like
clockwise or counterclockwise right and
then instantly instantly like No Time
Zero time this one moves uh for example
this one moves clockwise this one moves
counterclockwise or vice versa right
that's what they're saying they're
saying there's no mediator we have a
problem there because they're saying
there's nothing in between them why is
there nothing in between them because
they say we can't see or touch anything
through our experiments why can't you
well you got the wrong definition of
thing a thing is not that which you can
see or touch it's that which has shape
and this thing that's there has shape
but you cannot see or touch it that's
the first issue the second issue is that
hopefully there's something between
these two things because otherwise we're
all crazy we're doing black magic we're
doing action at a distance Okay so if
this changes instantaneously well we can
do it with a rope and here you can see
it very clearly and we'll do it this way
okay I want you to tell me I'm going to
twist the Rope right and uh how is the
Rope twisting according to your eyes
tell me is it counter clockwise or
counterclockwise
clockwise clockwise is it clock
clockwise over on my side it's
counterclockwise so strange okay let's
turn it the other way around how's it
twisting now for
you counter counter clockwise is
clockwise so we have
instantaneous clockwise and
counterclockwise which is what these
people cannot
explain light that's the photon turning
clockwise counterclockwise at two
separate points where they measure
That's What's happen so what happens
when you turn on a a flashlight
according to the Rope
hypothesis and the bean you see the bean
good question perect
question we have to let's start at the
Assumption the assumption is that all
atoms of your flashlight every single
atom right the smallest we got
gazillions of atoms in a flashlight but
all atoms especially those that
participate in the light uh phenomenon
right they're already attached to
whatever you're Illuminating so if
you're pointing the flashlight to the
wall every atom that from your bulb or
from the glass or whatever is already
connected to the wall okay okay but you
haven't turned the light on yet okay
it's turned off so you don't see
anything you say okay I've got the
flashlight here and the wall is dark you
know you don't there's nothing in
between suddenly you turn the light on
you you press a button right and
suddenly the wall illuminates right
suddenly you have a an image on the wall
what's has happened according to the
Rope model every Atom from your bulb to
every atom on the wall is already
connected and the ropes are in this
direction right in this case right
sideways right but here you're seeing it
from the flashlight to the wall and
they're toring all of them are torquing
okay so this is what's happening that
means that now they're in a frequency
they're in a speed right they're in a
torsion that comes visible to our eyes
because now that signal from the atom on
the wall is coming to your eye which is
also connected to that atom on the wall
before it was below a frequency that you
could not see suddenly you put the
flashlight now that same atom is
reflecting other it's torquing the Rope
that's connected to your eye so now you
see it why because it's within the
frequency that allows visible light okay
so you have this beam of all these atom
all these ropes connected they're all
torquing at a given frequency and that's
why we see this this light if you if you
uh you'll see some pictures out there
where that light is shining through a
gas sometimes through air whatever and
you see the reflection of that light
sideways and it comes to your eye
because it's hitting every atom of air
or whatever gas is there and it's that's
what's coming to your eye that's why you
can see the whole beam sideways because
every atom in between is is sending you
to the to your eyes through a rope
that's connected to your eyes is sending
you that signal sending you that
frequency and uh so yeah that's uh
that's essentially it it's it's
essentially a simple world that Mother
Nature has through the ropes but you
have to make that assumption that
everything is connected uh every atom is
connected to each other so we see the
light the
illumination because the ropes spin
faster right uh what you have is you
bring if if you have be below a certain
range you have what is infrared or
ultraviolet and you cannot see an except
within those two ranges so it's got to
be within that frequency for you to be
able to see it you know for the first
time so when you turn on when you have
the flashlight all the all the ropes are
already connected you don't see that
because it's below the frequency that
allows you to see it you can't touch
anything you can't touch any of the
ropes because they're Untouchable
unseeable so you say there's nothing
there but suddenly you turn the light on
and you say oh Magic suddenly all this
light shines by Magic on the wall wall
and you say oh Magic how did this happen
well all you did was rais the frequency
on each rope to the atoms on the wall
which now are shining at a they're
pumping faster they're also sending that
torsion to your eyes and that's why you
can see the light on the on the
wall okay that's the explanation it's a
relay mechanism not a bouncing ball
mechanism like quum
has okay so it let I mean let's assume
that all the uh atoms in the universe or
like the atoms in your room the the um
they were they just pulsated faster
would that mean that we could be if
let's just say they pulsated really fast
could that would that mean that we could
see the threads then you'll never see
the thread because you you can't see
atams let alone the Rope or the thread
which are much much thinner you know
than
than yeah talking about something
extremely thin that's imaginably thin
but it's you have to think of it is a
very thin thing that connects two atoms
but it's a physical thing that we cannot
see your touch okay but the only way
you're gonna see ropes is if you have
gazillions of them torquing at a given
speed and
uh what is it inducing other atoms to
pump because what they do when when the
at when the Rope torqus at a given speed
it forces the atom to pump at a bigger
speed so it's doing Quantum jump it's
going back and forth the the membrane is
expanding and Contracting which is
called the quantum jump right they have
a little bead going back and forth we
have the whole uh balloon expanding and
Contracting at a given speed very fast
and what it does it torque any rope
that's connected to that atom and also
forces that signal to be relayed to
another atom for example your eye okay
so so what we have is a relay what you
have in your room is a bunch bunch of
atoms uh of air of whatever you have in
your room and they're all pumping at a
given speed and you can stimulate them
by shining something atom and suddenly
you know that atom begins to pump faster
and sending the signal at a higher
torque to your eye and now it comes
within the visible range so if you enter
a dark room and there's a table there
you don't see it you turn the flashlight
on and suddenly the the table becomes
visible to you how did that magic Happ
happened it happened because every atom
of your flashlight is connected to every
atom of the table and every atom of the
table is connected to every atom of your
eye so now you you're torquing the ropes
at a higher frequency that allows the
atoms of the table to torque faster and
send that relay the signal to your eye
that's that's
what okay got it now alrighty well that
was a very good discussion a lot was
discussed and uh thanks again bill for
being on
on